you're making your Broadway debut in
meteor shower yes eh yeah this is
exciting
written by a scrappy young comic making
his way up named Steve Martin it got the
Commerce Department big up-and-comer huh
yeah haven't seen a lot of his stuff but
he was very promising it's been
interesting because in rehearsal
while we're rehearsing the play they do
tweaks every night so like that we
change things during the rehearsal
during the day so there are times when
the directors say so make sure don't do
the don't do that move you gonna do this
move tonight and then sometimes you're
like you're checking your phone you're
like no got it got it got it and then
cut to 8:30 at night it's just like you
know that's not like the lights come up
and you're like
[Laughter]
how do you handle the thing you know
they make people crazy a lot of actors
Broadway actors say they can't stand
when people were talking in the crowd oh
gosh yeah have you experienced that we
have experienced it well III did a I did
a production of Hamlet at the Public
Theater here in New York earlier this
year serious play and I'm sitting on the
steps like next to an audience member
and with Oscar Isaac and Oscar Isaac who
was playing Hamlet he sits down next to
this woman and this sweet little old
woman she's just looking at Oscar and
she just as loud as she possibly can she
just goes are they gonna carry you out
and he says he says I guess I don't know
I don't know put my watch watch watch
watch and this same old woman this same
old one in this poor lady she was just
having a day yeah she was having a
little bit of a time in the front row
and she was trying to be polite so while
a guy was doing a monologue she was like
I have to go to the bathroom I have to
go to the bathroom and looking wait I
can't wait to wait is that and he
stopped speaking in the monologue so her
to her to get her voice said he goes you
know the time thus and has happened here
I have to go number two
[Laughter]
[Applause]
but it's not it's not about being an
improv performer you're used to people
talking to you in stuff like that it's
like we even when you talk to them they
don't give you the response that you
always get people that come and watch
the the tapings whether it was here in
New York or in LA and they're so used to
watching the show on television yeah yet
they'll be sitting there and they'll
come out and they'll just go very loudly
he's taller than I thought I've got here
right here I'm here and sometimes I've
got I've gotten this up wing is he black
[Laughter]
[Applause]
voice isn't black is he Paula Nia well
damn it that was my next question
are you answering their questions I've
been half black for 46 years
and I'm all black when it's super
convenient right sometimes you have to
be all black sometimes you'd realize you
had that hour
yes I have that power
you